hey how's it going bros money is hot and
welcome to blood-borne Pete what are you
doing man that's right
send me a postcard [ __ ]
nothing can out damage the Oreo the
grater don't heal man
hmmm
oh never mind me oh-oh-oh
no one gets the Oreo there we go
I know that thing does a lot of damage
but so does my Oreo that's right
that's right hey brother
I got a gift for you have a nice trip
[ __ ] ha ha ha
to hell [ __ ] how you doing are
you doing
where you going mate here catch
Hey I guess he caught it
oh hey man where are you going
George everything [ __ ] come here Oh
how.what [ __ ] you there you go hey what
did you ah
ah I have no idea what's going on hey
catch I got um are you the real poo type
I what's that [ __ ] is the pro tip I what
are you gonna do
alright man you get you get the cannon
it's youtuber genius oh I don't know